In my last video, I discussed some patterns
I’d noticed during my time reviewing decks,
and there I gave 5 common deckbuilding
mistakes that I’ve seen people make. However,
that video only covered some of my observations,
with the other thing I calculated being how often
I suggested adding more of different types
of card to a deck. And, after interaction,
the second most common element here is a
tie between lands and ramp. To be honest,
this surprised me a little, particularly the
ramp part. Adding ramp feels like a somewhat
dated suggestion, a tip offered to newer players
in 2018 for how to keep up with the competition in
the hottest new format on the block. In 2025,
card draw and synergy feel like bigger focal
points for EDH critique, with a trendy hot take
these days being that people run too much ramp,
that the focus on ramp of the past decade has
gone too far in some cases. And, undoubtedly,
there is probably some truth to that—ramp has
become an accepted part of every deck, and adding
ramp to a deck without thinking about why you’re
adding it is both a commonplace action for people,
and a recipe for decks that aren’t as lean and
powerful as they could be. And yet, there have
been 9 decks I’ve seen that I thought needed more
ramp, as opposed to only 6 that needed more draw.
So in this video, I want to get to the bottom of
that discrepancy, and hopefully build a framework
that can help you tell if your deck is in need
of ramp, or in need of something that’s not ramp.
Why ramp?
The first point that needs to be made is that
ramp spells don’t fulfill one single task. Rather,
they perform two separate functions—curving
out, and increasing total mana quantity. Let’s
start with the first one of those. What I mean by
curving out is deploying your cards in an order
and on a timeline that lets your deck best perform
its gameplan in the first five turns of the game.
If we consider a dinosaur deck as an example,
most Pantlaza players would probably prefer to
get him out on turn 4, since Dinosaurs played
after him generate extra value and dinosaurs
played before him do not. If we assume that
most ramp spells ramp for a single mana,
this means that we need to choose whether we
want that ramp to happen on turn 1, 2, or 3,
or what mixture of those values we’d prefer.
Let’s map out those different options—with
a turn 1 ramp spell, we skip 2 mana and have
turns with 3 and 4 mana in addition to the turn
4 Pantlaza. With a turn 2 ramp spell, we skip 3
mana and have a single 4 mana turn before our 5
mana Pantlaza turn. With a 3 mana ramp spell,
we have 1 and 2 mana turns, but skip directly
to 5 without a 4 mana turn. So, how do we make
our decision between these different options?
On a basic level, it might just be coordinating
with the mana values of the non-ramp cards. If
I have lots of 4 drops I like and not many two
drops, adding a bunch of 2-cost ramp works out
well. If I have some setup plays I want to make
with two mana and not much on three or four mana,
adding some three cost ramp likely works well with
that. There are a couple other factors, though,
such as that some ramp will simply be better for
our deck than other ramp. Ramping on turn 1 is
theoretically the most efficient from a mana-spent
standpoint, but basically all 1 mana ramp will be
in the form of mana dorks, which could amplify
the weakness to boardwipes that already exists
for dinosaur decks. Meanwhile, though 3 mana
ramp is less mana efficient and takes up an
often-contested mana slot, it’s also likely to
have upsides beyond just boosting us up 1 mana,
and additionally might contain more cards that
synergize with the rest of our gameplan. If we
have lots of great plays to land on 3 and 4
mana that one mana dork might still be great,
but it’s all about weighing the risk vs the
reward, and there are plenty of decks where
the reward won’t be great enough. One final
consideration is how taplands affect our
curve. If you build the most optimized possible
mana base you could probably mostly avoid these,
but this may not even be necessary. Lots of
mana curves build in a bit of breathing room
where they can play a tapland consequence-free,
often on turn 1 but also on later turns as well.
With our hypothetical dino deck, I’d expect
a pretty normal curve to be nothing turn 1,
a ramp spell turn 2, and 3 mana
card turn 3, and Pantlaza turn 4,
and that curve gives us two different places
to play a tapped land. Budget players, rejoice!
So that’s curveout. The other function of mana
ramp is to increase the total amount of mana a
player has, agnostic to the timing of any one
card. The easiest example of this is high-cost
commanders—you might run some ramp to curve into
it, but if you have a 6 or 7 mana commander that
poses a major threat, command tax is probably
going to be the bigger factor that compels you
to ramp. A deck with a high-30s land count is
naturally going to start missing land drops
around turn 6 absent any draw or filtering, and
even if you manage to hit every single land drop,
the escalating cost of a commander can get
pretty painful to keep forking over. So, this
is the other thing ramp does—it works alongside a
deck’s land count to keep total mana increasing.
Aside from an expensive commander, there are a
few other reasons you might want your mana to
keep increasing. One is that you’re playing a deck
with a lot of card draw and other ways to churn
through your mana, but where your gameplan isn’t
all that fast. In principle spending more mana is
a good starting point for trying to win EDH games,
though there will be differences in how much mana
is required to win. Some decks will be lean and
proactive enough to be able to win by spending
only 20 mana, whereas others might take 30, 40,
or even more than that. If you’re just getting
started with a new deck, or even just getting into
the format, a good starting point will be to aim
high with both draw and ramp, since you might
not know the amount of mana you need to win.
If it ends up being higher than expected, you’ll
be glad to have a deck with more draw and ramp,
whose gameplan is volumetrically larger and
prepared to play later into the game. As a final
precaution, if increased maximum mana is the role
of ramp you’re leaning into, you’re going to be
best-served to prioritize more permanent forms of
ramp—preferably land ramp, mana rocks in a pinch,
and mana dorks at your own caution. An Elvish
Mystic will be great for a buttery-smooth
curveout, but an EDH game is a hostile climate
for a squishy guy like that in the long term.
Why not ramp?
So, these are the reasons why you might
want to play a lot of ramp in your deck,
and I do think it is helpful to start by laying
them out like this. However, this leaves a
couple other questions still on the table. For
one, how much ramp should a deck be running,
assuming it wants it in the first place? Well, if
we’re talking about ramp for curveout purposes,
this is a thing you can quantify pretty well
ahead of time. Figure out your target you’re
ramping to and the appropriate mana values of
ramp to get you there, and then shove it into
a hypergeometric calculator. You can find such a
calculator on my website, linked in description,
and you can also use one built into a deckbuilding
website. Looking at my Radha deck, you can see
that Archidekt gives a 77% chance of a ramp spell
playable on turn 3 in my opening hand with 18
copies in the deck, and this is a comfortable
figure for me since it’s a type of card I’ll
always want. You can also tweak the cards-draw
parameter to match the amount of cards you’ve
seen by the turn you’ll want something, though
only do that if you’re okay keeping opening hands
without it. Also, if you don’t want to
do any math, here are some benchmarks:
18 cards of a certain role, like we see
here, is a good number if you always want
to see it in your opening hand, and
are okay getting multiple sometimes
15 is a healthy total if it’s a tool you want
every game, but there’s a bit of wiggle room for
alternate paths, or maybe some early filtering
12 is nice for if you want a tool in most games
but some have alternate options for curving out
9 is good for if a thing is a frequent part
of your curve-out, but not a core part
Finally, 6 is good for a thing you want
sometimes, and 3 is good for a thing you
don’t really want to draw early very often
All of this is for the “curving out” purpose
of ramp. For the total-mana function of ramp,
it’s going to be easier to feel it out
than anything else. My Sharuum deck’s
ramp suite is pretty narrow on paper, but
in practice it feels like just enough to
let me achieve a mana advantage in the
late game, which can be really helpful
for a control deck that wants to outscale
opponents. Relevantly to the point here,
that goldilocks total was the product of dozens
of games feeling out the deck’s needs. However,
that advice might not give you any helpful
information in the here and now, so I’ll now pivot
to answering a second question that might offer
a bit of insight—when does a deck not want ramp?
Conveniently, the answer to this question is
kinda just the inverse of the two reasons for
wanting ramp I laid out earlier. Let’s think
about mana curve—if you’re playing a deck
with a lot of important low-cost plays, you
might not have a turn where you even want to
be playing a mana rock. I have a Meria voltron
deck that is packed with 1 and 2 mana equipment,
and since I’m building around a 3 mana
commander that means that my turns 1-3
are basically already spoken for. Going purely
by the standard of curveout, this deck wouldn’t
want any ramp at all. However, I still do run a
moderate quantity of mostly-equipment-based ramp,
and that’s because this deck always, always wants
to be able to pay commander tax. My commander is
a big part of my value and my plan for winning,
and her Urza-like presence is massively important
to the deck’s mana economy. While being a 3-cost
commander helps in recastability, I still like to
be able to stockpile a bit of extra total mana
just in case I end up needing to recast her. So
this is a deck that doesn’t want ramp for curveout
reasons, but does want it for total mana reasons.
For a point of contrast, we can think about a
deck that doesn’t want ramp for either of these
two reasons. My Malfegor deck runs very
little ramp, and looking at its gameplan
it’s not too hard to see why. My curve is
heaviest on 3 mana, followed by 2 mana,
with most of these being either engines to build
in value or discard spells to strip resources
away from opponents. Since I don’t really
consistent turn 4 or 5 plays, a mana rock
would do absolutely nothing for this deck’s early
game. Importantly, this deck also doesn’t need
total mana—the goal of it is to push all players,
myself included, into a low-resources state,
and even with a draw engine or two up I’m still
not going to be drawing that much mana worth of
stuff since my curve is moderately low. Previous
iterations of this deck had a lower land count,
and ramp felt useful there for casting the
commander, but I’ve since come to the conclusion
that consistent land drops are really all that’s
needed to keep up with Malfegor’s command tax,
so the total-mana reason for ramp kind of just
evaporated with a few extra lands in the mix.
I mentioned earlier that high counts of draw
and ramp is going to be a solid starting point
for a lot of decks, and that is true, but as you
get a feel for a deck you might find that your
counts can be a bit lower. Maybe your deck is more
efficient and simply needs less mana in general,
or maybe your deck is like my Malfegor deck—not
necessarily wildly fast or powerful, but also not
looking to pump up the scale of its gameplay
a whole lot, even in a late-game scenario.
As a final point, let’s just back to the idea of
lands being a replacement for ramp in some cases.
This is an idea that has been bubbling just
below the surface in EDH discourse for several
years now. A couple of extremely talented magic
players—Frank Karsten and Sam Black—have each
weighed in on this relationship, and both came to
the conclusion through use of simulations or other
mathematical means that the average EDH deck would
be served well to focus more on land count and
less on quantity of ramp. While I would hesitate
to endorse the exact numbers they’ve come up with,
or really any exact numbers given the many
layers of complexity in the commander format,
the fundamentals of the critique still hold
true. A lot of ramp and a low land count is
frequently a recipe for inefficiency.
Now, land count is an area where a lot
of commander players have shifted in the past
couple years—no longer are we in an era where
35-36 lands is universally accepted as a good
starting point for a deck’s land count. Still,
the inertia of the previous eras of commander
wisdom still means that a lot of players haven’t
followed this shift. One might ask, are they
justified in this? Sometimes. Some decks don’t
need that many lands—they don’t need much mana
to do what they want to do, they have options
for early filtering that can find them more lands,
or their deck benefits enough from maximizing gas
that it’s worth it to sometimes miss a land
drop—an example of this I gave in my lands
video at the start of this year was pseudo-storm
commanders such as Jhoira, Weatherlight Captain.
Whether or not your deck is justified in running
a lower land count for one of these reasons might
not be a simple judgment to make, but here’s a
basic test you should try running. Whenever you
miss a land drop with a piece of ramp in hand,
or a piece of ramp that was recently played,
make note of that. If that is happening for
you every game or even multiple times per game,
that’s an indication that you probably need
to swap some ramp spells for some lands.
Thanks for watching! And thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
Archidekt’s tools for visualizing categories
make it a lot easier to figure out questions
of lands and ramp. How early does my draw and
filtering come online? About that early. What
does my curve look like after I cut out the
instants I know I’ll be using reactively rather
than playing on curve? It looks like that. A
link to my decks is in the description if you
want to play around with these tools on decks
I’ve built. I also want to thank my supporters,
some of whom are onscreen now. If you want to
join this illustrious crowd, you can become
a YouTube member or sign up for my Patreon. With
that said, I hope you have a lovely new year. Bye!